101 october survivors loved ones and
community members gathered tonight
there's still some people here at the
site right now it was very emotional for
many of them to come back to the place
where this all happened but they say it
was important to be together they were
let inside the festival grounds to form
a human chain showing strength and unity
in the face of tragedy mgm resorts
international tells us event parking is
planned for near-term use of the site
but back in august the company announced
their donation of two acres of property
for a memorial site no memorial design
has been set yet but we asked survivors
of the shooting what they would want to
see
some
kind of almost like we saw on the las
vegas sign of all the names of all the
people so that none of those people are
ever forgotten those names are never
forgotten ever whether we gather or
whether you can come individually and
just sit
and just kind of be in that space
according to the las vegas resiliency
center the community is heavily involved
in making the memorial a reality the
design process is set to begin later
this month until then survivors tell us
they will continue to lean on each other
and this community which has proven to
be vegas stronger reporting live tonight
orca mana live local now